هنا الابوابه مطار فلوج بجنوب السودان
ازدهرت حركه تجاريه نسويه من الاصيله
البحريه لسد حاجه العالقين من الطعام
باسعار زهيده فالناس هنا يعانون الانتظار
وقله الطعام
نازل كانوا تعبانين
بلينا اشترينا الرز وعدس وجنجرو ونعمل
مدينه حاجات
نازل تعبانين يعني بتلقي واحد عنده ميه
لك بيقول لك انا جعانه
فيما استقرت الهام سليمان التي تقطن منطقه
جودا الشماليه الاباء المانجه لسد حاجه
الاسره التي تعاني اوضاء مائشيه صعبه
بعدما فقد رب المنزل وظيفته اليوميه نتيجه
لحاله الحرب في البلاد
شر عيالك ملاح ان شاء الله كمونيه وهيك بس
اذا هكذا تبدو الصوره فالجميع يشكو من
انعدام السيوله وبصعوبه يستطيع النازه
تغطيه مصاريف وجبه واحده ناهيك من مياح
الشرب عند المواجع ما في
وبعدين انا
خمسه يوم والله قاعد
معقول
وما بين هذا وذاك ستظل الحرب واثارها صوره
معلمه في اذهان الكثيرين فمن هرب من الحرب
واجهته حرب اخرى
مصائب قوم عند قوم فوائد وان كانت متفاوته
في اسعار الاطعمه التي تعرض هنا الا انها
استطاعت ان تسد حاجه الكثيرنه في ظل عظام
الطعام هنا
العربيه مطار فلوج جنوب السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات